the 49ers make their move up the
dolphins make their move
down then the dolphins make their move
up and it's a crazy day
of trades in the nfl with the draft
roughly a month away five weeks four
weeks and six days away
here's the thing that got it started
49ers moved from 12
up to number three in a trade with the
mayan emmy dolphins
the pick the dolphins got as part of the
laramie tunsil trade from labor day
weekend of 2019
it's originally a texans pick it's now
the 49ers pick
and the dolphins get pick number 12
first round pick in 2022
third round pick in 2022 and a first
round pick in 2023.
this is kyle shanahan's version of the
rg3 trait plain and simple and he was
the offensive coordinator in washington
nine years ago when washington went from
six
to two with two other first round picks
and a second round pick
now the move is from 12
to three but it's the 12th pick two
first rounders
third round pick next year not exactly
the same
total of compensation not exactly the
same height
in the draft but it puts the 49ers at
number three miles
and everyone assumes they're at number
three for one reason
they're looking for a new qb1 yeah
that's the only reason why you make a
move of this magnitude
is to go up and to draft a quarterback
and especially
in a draft where we assume there are
four to five
quarterbacks that are going to be
drafted pretty early at least
in that first round so by doing this
it's almost like
kyle shanahan's looking around and he
sees his buddy matt lafleur is in green
bay he's got aaron rodgers and he sees
his buddy down
in los angeles sean mcvay he just went
and got matthew stafford and it's like
well wait a minute
no no no no no i just i can't just have
jimmy garoppolo when i can't just be
doing this anymore i have to go and i
have to go get my guy
and i have to get somebody who i can
believe that i can train
in order to be an elite quarterback
that's going to not just get me to the
super bowl
but win the super bowl because we got a
defense
that is playoff ready that is playoff
caliber obviously as long as it's
healthy
they just have to be able to make sure
that they've got the offense to match it
and the whole believe nothing vibe that
we played at the top of the show
was in honor of things that have been
said
and are being said about the 49ers
commitment
to quarterback jimmy garoppolo who is
entering the
next to last year of his long-term deal
five years 27.5 million due to make 25
million in total compensation
this year from the 49ers first let's
hear
from john lynch last month when
as we told you at the time he said what
he had
to say here he is if he's
injury-free is there any doubt in your
mind that jimmy garoppolo is your
quarterback when you line up in
september
no not at all i mean i i really believe
that he uh
you know i just look at the numbers i
mean he's 25
and 24 9 25 and 9 when he's played um
you know though being available is a big
part of this thing so like i said we we
probably as a
stated goal we have to insulate
ourselves better and we got to have
better options if he's not there
um but you know i've watched people go
through this in the career where they
struggle it happened to me early and
then i went eight years without missing
a practice so
i believe that things can happen i i
believe they will for him and
and you know i really believe that jimmy
is our guy
now that's what he said then and
today they're putting the word out that
jimmy is still
the guy shefty had the
anonymous source saying jimmy is here to
stay he's our guy this year
why does that have to be anonymous if
that's true why is it an unnamed source
i i know that that's kind of how the
sausage gets made
but this is something that if it's true
the 49ers should be able to attach a
name to it right
we have no intent to trade percy harvin
at least rick spielman was willing to
say it
so he could be called out on it later on
oh hey well you know if they trade or
cut jimmy garoppolo it's kind of hard to
say well but if that unnamed source that
told jeffy
that uh that jimmy garoppolo is going to
be on the team this year so
i guess there's still a chance he will
be i don't
buy it i don't believe it he'd have to
take a lot less money i think
to stay and he'd have to know that
if he gets cut whatever the 49ers are
offering him is as good or better than
what someone else would pay him if he
became a free agent
but i think the chances of jimmy
garoppolo returning to the 49ers at 25
million this year miles
are very very small at this point and if
they would do it
they're stupid oh absolutely look and
it's only going to take i think a little
under 3 million in dead money to cut him
there's there's no reason why jimmy
garoppolo should be back
on the same contract that he's at right
now there just is no reason why
especially
if you have made this move to trade up
to three as we said to start the show
you only do that if you are picking up a
quarterback
so at this point you know if you're
jimmy garoppolo you're looking around
and you're thinking man this is
this is probably not the best thing for
me maybe
you start thinking maybe i should
request a trade and i don't know how
many people out there
would say yeah i'm going to trade for
this contract
from jimmy garoppolo right now because
it's basically a situation where either
he gets traded and somebody takes on
that contract
or then the 49ers decide that they're
going to cut him
and then somebody maybe swoops in and
says hey 49ers will give you this
but jimmy you're going to have to redo
your contract in order to come here with
us
it's just a situation right now where
did garoppolo is probably
not in the best shape um from a
financial standpoint at least going into
this next year
because look he's got a lot to prove
because unfortunately he just has not
stayed healthy
for the balance of his career when he's
been a starter for the 49ers so
there's going to be some probably tough
conversations that are going to have to
happen
but i think you know from the starting
standpoint no
we should not be believing folks right
now especially if they're just saying
anonymously
oh yeah jimmy garoppolo is here to stay
i don't think so
because you know for whether it was dave
gellman you know saying that odell is
we didn't sign him to trade him and then
drink in the water and that water bottle
and that is the you know the supporting
player and it's hilarious
it just you can't believe what they're
saying right now
there is one way to make a trade happen
and the parallel would be
what the raiders were able to do with
trent brown who took
a restructured contract less money a
path to free agency after one year
as part of a trade to the new england
patriots the 49ers
could say to garoppolo and to whoever
his top
suitor may be let's say it's the
patriots again
here's what we're going to do we will
eventually cut him
but we're not cutting him until whenever
we feel like it we're not cutting until
the first day of training camp
you want him now you want to get it
started now
jimmy you take whatever the patriots
would pay you as a free agent
patriots you give us something and we do
this now otherwise
we're content to carry 25 million on our
salary cap we already had it budgeted
we're good to go
and if we draft a quarterback with the
third overall pick it's not like it's a
huge cap number
for this year tied up in that guy so
that's a way
to do it when it otherwise would be a
situation where all jimmy garoppolo has
to say is i'm not
reducing my salary at
any bit at all you're going to have to
cut me the 49ers have the benefit of
waiting
we're in the out years of the contract
where there isn't a trigger
that makes money guaranteed there's no
roster bonus there's nothing that the
49ers have to do this year
to make it happen and you know what
jimmy garoppolo could get out of it he
could say
i'll take less this year and we wipe out
the final year of my contract so become
a free agent after this season that's a
way that a trade
could happen because we've seen that
template between the raiders
and the patriots so that's a possibility
but again
again no one's paying jimmy garoppolo
25 million this year no one in their
right mind should be paying jimmy
garoppolo
25 million this year in large part
because he has not proven he can stay
healthy the market's softened he can't
stay healthy
and he
you know the system works but it's not
because of him that the system works
so people say to me all the time why do
you hate jimmy garoppolo i don't hate
jimmy garoppolo i like
honesty with the audience i'm not gonna
shake pom poms just for the sake of
saying go
49ers so 49ers fans are happy with what
they hear when they tune into this show
who does that serve really folks i mean
seriously
there are plenty of other networks well
at least one
where you will get pom pom waving all
the time
and you're rarely going to get any real
criticism especially in the morning
do you really want that or do you want
to know what's really going on do you
want to know what people are really
saying and what people really think
miles you don't need to respond to this
you still have a career in front of you
i'm on the back uh
the back nine i'm in the final three i'm
on that par three right before you hole
out and go
drink a beer and eat a hamburger so um
not really uh not really i'm gonna i'm
i'm gonna die with my boots on the
question is when will that happen but
but what was i saying again um i i i
don't hate jimmy garoppolo talking i
don't
i like i like truth i like honesty
i like authenticity and i like
quarterbacks who can play
period call me crazy i like quarterbacks
who can play
well i mean who aren't able to play is
availability right so that's that's what
people all
talk about in that clip we played of
john lynch he even was talking about
how the jimmy garoppolo has to be
available and when he plays
and he he has to be able to play in
order for him to play well
right so that step a has to come before
step b
so i think it makes sense what you're
saying that
you you don't necessarily have to be a
jimmy garoppolo hater
in order to think yes jimmy garoppolo
needs to actually be
out there in order for him to have some
sort of value
to the 49ers and well at this point
though i i believe jimmy garoppolo has a
no trade clause i saw that
you know i've seen that reported so
right right but yeah right he'd have to
wave it right
right yeah look miles miles
the no trade clause the no trade clause
is no no no no no you didn't do anything
but no one is trading for a starting
quarterback that doesn't want to be
there
the no trade clause is meaningful yes
absolutely the bears didn't trade for
carson wentz
because he didn't want to be there he
didn't have a no trade clause but he
didn't want to go to chicago so the
bears didn't make an offer so i just i
like to point that out when people act
like the no trade clause means something
not that you did
but people have been saying that all day
you didn't even let me say what i was
going to say
sorry sorry it triggered me i know
it's as bad as calling me an old timer i
i guess so
but no i just think that if it's going
if it has to be that it
all it matters is that as you just said
that he's going to go somewhere that he
wants to be
and we would have to think that he might
want to be in new england
because he's already familiar with that
that team
with that structure with the way that
they do things the patriot way if we
want to go there and call it that
so it wouldn't make a lot of sense if
jimmy garoppolo were to say hey if this
is the way it's gonna be
let's just trade me back to the patriots
and we'll see if we can work something
out and maybe he could do exactly as you
were saying before about the trent brown
thing right
he could do his own little version of
that figure out the way to get back
there reduce the contract to whatever
they need it to be
so that he can go back to where he would
want to be and play for new england and
play in an offensive system he already
knows
you were right you were wrong goodness
uh yes
that's it's funny i see i see a tweet
from tim kawakami
of the athletic from just before we went
on the air i think a lot of people are
completely misreading the garoppolo
situation the 49ers think they can win
the super bowl this season
that isn't likely with the rookie
quarterback starting unless they get a
tremendous offer
why give up the super bowl shot by
moving garoppolo no no
you're not going to pay garoppolo 25
million dollars you're not going all in
for a quarterback right now to get a
quarterback
right now and keeping garoppolo and
paying him 25 million and having
a rookie third overall pick that you
gave up all that stuff to get
on the bench behind him as as his backup
that isn't happening kyle shanahan made
this move
because there is one
or two or three quarterbacks that he
would be happy to get in that spot
and let's pivot to that angle here
because i don't i i think the 49ers
are going to do everything they can they
will
burn every reporter they can they will
lie to everyone they can to try to build
a trade market for jimmy garoppolo
and go ahead and swallow the hook if you
want to tim kawakami
adam schefter anyone else because i
choose to believe they're lying because
they have a reason to
they want to trade jimmy garoppolo and
they want to get back the second round
pick they gave up for him
four years ago i don't think they're
keeping him so
regardless of whether or not they keep
it you've got
three three picks jaguars
jets 49ers jaguars take trevor lawrence
jets take zach wilson assuming they do
we don't know that
we don't know that maybe maybe maybe
robert salas said something to kyle
shanahan that
got shanahan's attention but even if the
jets aren't sold on wilson
you have to worry about the jets trading
out of that spot to someone who is
so you have to be content to see
lawrence and wilson
go and then who do you take at three
and shanahan already is he would not be
giving
up those first round picks if he was not
a complete believer
in lawrence wilson and another guy
we just don't know who the other guy is
sims close friend of shanahan
although shanahan doesn't talk to him
because sims is a big mouth
even with without the influence of
the things he smokes on thursday friday
and saturday nights but even
even then uh he's not going to trust him
so mac jones is the guy that sims thinks
is most
game ready learn shanahan system come in
make the throws get it done so it's mac
jones
look it's mac jones trey lance or justin
fields and there are people out there
saying it's lancer fields
sims thinks it's mac jones whoever it is
there's a guy after lawrence and wilson
that shanahan believes in enough to give
up
12th overall pick two future first
rounders third round pick
that means you're putting that guy on
the field that
you're not doing that so you can just
say
you sit and learn for a year like
patrick mahomes did that's not working
that's not happening because they
wouldn't do this if they believed in
jimmy garoppolo
see if you believe in jimmy garoppolo
you don't make this move
if you don't believe in jimmy garoppolo
you don't make this move and say we're
sticking with jimmy for one more year
that's why it's all bs in my opinion
watch garoppolo be the quarterback wire
to wire and win the freaking super bowl
wow there's a lot that uh i could
respond to there that you just
uh that you just went there but i i
think the one thing that you
i think didn't say but there was a lot
that you said was that if
the the niners knew that the jets were
not going to go after a quarterback
then it probably would make sense that
the niners would go up to number two
instead right because you got to think
about this robert sala
is coming from san francisco so
ostensibly those guys are going to talk
a little bit
i i just i feel like if the jets
were in a position where they were gonna
stick with sam darnold and they weren't
actually going to either draft zach
wilson or whoever else at number two
overall
then they would probably be more
inclined
to trade back maybe it wouldn't be with
san francisco because that's a little
bit too far from
them but there would probably be
something where
you're saying to kyle shanahan if you're
robert sal hey man
if you want this number two overall pick
come and get it because
we're not gonna draft a quarterback so
if there if there is not that knowledge
then it just seems like the jets are
probably gonna stay at two overall
and they're gonna draft their next qb
and then from there
you're gonna have the 49ers who are
going to pick third overall
it's almost a little bit like i think
when uh the rams traded up to one
back in 16 and they get jared goff and
the eagles
knew that so they still traded up to two
and they said yes we're gonna get carson
once that's the guy we want anyway so
there just has to be some sort of
understanding
or some sort of knowledge that you're
gonna get who you want
in order to make this kind of deal
happen because it's not just this year's
first round pick it's 2022 and 2023.
you don't just give that up if you're
not getting the guy who you know
you want yep i agree with you completely
and i think that moving to three is a
concession
that it's gonna be lawrence wilson and
then
you have the run of the board after
those first two
if it's jones if it's lance if it's
fields
you get the guy you want and you've
already decided that's your guy and
again
this is just common sense sometimes you
have to ignore
what sources are telling you or whatever
pr
spin a team is trying to to
fill your head with and just look at it
and say as i said
you don't make this move if
you're content to stick with jimmy
garoppolo
if you're content to stick with jimmy
garoppolo he's your guy so you by making
this move you're telling the world you
you can't continue
with jimmy g they're just being more sly
about it than the rams were
plain and simple the rams the rams
showed their cards
and what they have to do they had to
give a first round pick to get jared
goff off the books because of all that
guaranteed money so i think we're on the
same page
and and and i think it's jones i believe
i believe sims
i i think it's going to be jones mac
jones the alabama quarterback who
who looks like a throwback and looks
goofy and clunky in his uniform like
bobby lane or joe capp
way before your time before my time for
the most part too
but yeah who are they thank you um but
uh but but he can get it done and he has
and
is it a coincidence is it a coincidence
that this trade happens
just days after we saw mack jones throw
the ball at his pro day workout
i don't i don't think it's a coincidence
that that's when it got finalized
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports